[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute Mitri
Serin einen schönen guten Abend für den
Sport ist Christin wieder da gern guten
Abend dann schauen wir jetzt was wir in
der Sendung
haben erfolgreicher Stimmungstest
US-Präsident Biden hat die erste Vorwahl
der Demokraten klar
gewonnen tödliche Flammen bei schweren
Wald in Chile sind dutzende Menschen ums
Leben
gekommen und Deutschland ist
Europameister die Hockey
Herrenmannschaft setzt sich im
hallenfinale gegen Polen
durch in den USA sieht es aktuell wieder
stark nach einem präsidentschaftsduell
Biden gegen Trump aus Joe Biden hat den
vorwahlauftagt seiner Demokraten in
South Carolina gewonnen und das noch
deutlicher als Trump bei den
Republikanern allerdings gibt es in der
Demokratischen Anhängerschaft auch
Zweifel an beiden und die haben auch
etwas mit seinen inzwischen 81 Jahren zu
tun Elma
twiisen sie feiern über 96% für Joe
Biden er ist nur zugeschaltet stellt
aber gleich die entscheidende
Frage nach der Wahlbeteiligung die trübt
seinen Sieg nur rund 13 000 Wähler
machten mit 2020 waren es über eine
halbe Million damals gab es mit
demokratischen Kandidaten mehr
Wettbewerb diesmal fehlt die
Begeisterung er hat noch viel Arbeit vor
sich auch wenn er bisher einen tollen
Job gemacht
hat dabei haben seine Unterstützer
überall geworben dass die Menschen zur
Wahl gehen aber viele halten beiden für
zu alt auch wenn er wie hier im
Barbershop von seinen Erfolgen besonders
für die schwarze Minderheit erzählt
Millionen Menschen aus der Armut
geholfen eine schwachzes oberste
Bundesrichterin Schuldenerlasse für
Studenten KZ sollten alle mal aufstehen
die Verwandte und Bekannte haben die
beiden nicht wählen
wollen es geht nicht nur um sein Alter
besonders junge Wähler halten beiden für
zu Israel freundlich er tu zu wenig für
die
Palästinenser mitten im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf geschieht ein
Völkermord das macht mich ganz
fertig viele Demokraten ärgert seine
gazolitik aber statt zu sagen ich habe
recht sollte er lieber klar machen sein
Gegner Trump viel schlimmer wäre das
erfordert einen sehr sehr negativen
Wahlkampf brutal und hässlich aber das
ist bidens beste
Chance in Kalifornien Nevada und New
York will er diese Woche Donald Trump
als Gefahr für die Demokratie darstellen
damit die Angst mehr Wähler
mobilisiert weiterhin hoch halten die
USA ihren militärischen Druck gegen
pro-iranische Milizen im Nahen Osten
einen Tag nach ihren Luftangriffen im
Irak und Syrien attackierten sie
gemeinsam mit Großbritannien und anderen
Partnern 36 Ziele an 13 Orten im Jemen
die hui die mit dem Iran verbündet sind
und immer wieder internationale
Handelsschiffe im Roten Meer beschießen
kündigten Vergeltung
an in Chile wüten zurzeit die
schlimmsten Brände seit Jahren die
Regierung spricht bis jetzt von
mindestens 64 Toten es ist aber davon
auszugehen dass noch viel mehr Opfer
gefunden werden am heftigsten betroffen
ist vinja Delmar eine Nachbarstadt von
wparaiso in der gesamten Küstenregion
herrscht seit Monaten extreme Hitze und
Dürre ausgelöst durch das Wetterphänomen
el ninho Christoph
röckerat die explodierenden Gastanks
sind für die Feuerwehr das Signal zum
Rückzug sie haben keine Chance die
Brandkatastrophe ist weiter außer
Kontrolle in der chilenischen
Küstenregion walparaisu westlich der
Hauptstadt S
von zahlreichen Todesopfern und
Vermissten ist bislang die
[Musik]
Rede auf einmal hieß es wir seinen vom
Feuer umzingelt es hatte im Botanischen
Garten begonnen und kam dann zu
uns wir können nichts tun um unsere
Häuser zu retten wir müssen zuschauen
und warten bis sie abgebrannt sind und
das Feuer von selbst
ausgeht tausende Anwohner sind auf der
Flucht Menschen die weiter von den
Brandherden entfernt leben wurden
dagegen aufgefordert in ihren Häusern zu
bleiben damit die Rettungsdienste
durchkommen die Feuerwehr hat bislang
kaum eine Chance gegen die
Brände wir haben hier Winde von 40 bis
50 stundenkilomet das ist ein Problem
weil der Wind kleine Zweige und Blätter
mit sich trägt die weitere Feuer
starten Chiles Präsident Gabriel borit
hat in Ausnahmezustand verhängt und das
Militär zur Hilfe entsandt aufgrund der
Vielzahl der gleichzeitig ausgebrochenen
Brand Herde gibt es den Verdacht dass
einige Feuer absichtlich gelegt worden
sein
könnten sie können sicher sein dass wir
dies vollumfänglich ermitteln und hart
bestrafen
werden das Ausmaß der Katastrophe ist
noch nicht abzusehen die Zahl der Opfer
dürfte weiter
ansteigen zurück ins Innland auch heute
sind in mehreren Städten wieder
zahlreiche Menschen gegen
Rechtsextremismus auf die Straße
gegangen in Bremen zogen rund 16000
durch die Innenstadt etwas weniger als
von den Organisatoren erwartet und auch
im sächsischen Freiberg versammelten
sich hunderte Menschen in Sachsen ist
die AFD besonders stark sie könnte bei
den Landtagswahlen im Herbst stärkste
Kraft
werden heute ist Weltkrebstag darum
jetzt ein genauerer Blick auf das Leiden
Krebs ist nämlich die zweithäufigste
Todesursache in Deutschland nach
Herzkreislauferkrankungen 20 sind gut
231500 Menschen an den Folgen von Krebs
gestorben 2002 waren es rund 20 000 am
häufigsten wurden Patientinnen und
Patienten mit Lungen und bronchalkrebs
im Krankenhaus versorgt gefolgt von den
Diagnosen Darm und Brustkrebs die
Chancen auf Heilung steigen mit besseren
Therapien und mehr Vorsorge Petra
Otto fast 5 Jahre ist es her der htbat
Fall Brustkrebs einen sogenannten
hormonabhängigen Tumor der sehr häufig
ist um das Rückfallrisiko zu senken
nimmt sie nun ein Medikament nämlich
Anastrozol und genau das ist jetzt in
Großbritannien und den USA sogar
vorbeugen zugelassen ein neuer Weg
Krebsprävention mit Tabletten kannst von
mir nicht vorstellen diese ganze
Medikamente hfach nwikung und Z wohl
eben deshalb ist man in Deutschland mit
der Zulassung von Anastrozol zur
Krebsvorbeugung zurückhaltend obwohl die
Wirksamkeit belegt ist in den Studien
wurde gezeigt dass Anastrozol das Risiko
etwa halbieren kann in den nächsten 5
Jahren an Brustkrebs zu erkranken dem
gegenüber hat man natürlich dann auch
Nebenwirkungen mit denen man rechnen
muss wie Hitzewallungen
Schweißausbrüche Knochenschmerzen
Gelenkbeschwerden Nebenwirkungen die die
Lebensqualität enorm einschränken
deshalb setzt eher mehr auf Sport und
gesunde Ernährung als auf Pillen ich
würde mit der Empfehlung an eine
Patientin es zu neehmen sehr
differenziert umgehen aber ich wäre
mutig aufgrund der Studiendaten das
Medikament zuzulassen zumindest für
risikopatientin denn Krebsprävention
heißt längst nicht mehr nur kein Alkohol
nicht rauchen sie wird immer
vielfältiger Besucher die mit schweren
vs in Paris im öffentlichen Raum parken
sollen nach dem Willen der
Stadtverwaltung künftig das Dreifache
Zahlen heute läuft dazu eine Abstimmung
konkret geht es um mindestens 18 € pro
Stunde statt bisher 6 € Anwohner sollen
davon komplett ausgenommen werden
französische Autoclubs werden die Pläne
als stsschuss um Autos komplett aus
Paris zu verbannen das Ergebnis wird am
späten Abend
erwartet aufatmen können Pendler die
regelmäßig zwischen Leverkusen und Köln
den Rhein überqueren müssen nach 7
Jahren Bauzeit wurde die neue A1 Brücke
freigegeben erst wenn die alte Brücke
abgerissen ist wird das neue Bauwerk
komplett fertig gestellt und dann in
voller Breite auf dem stark befahrenen
Streckenabschnitt zur Verfügung
stehen so jetzt zum Sport und einem
tollen Erfolg für die deutschen
Hockeyspieler Christin em Gold wie schön
die Männer von Bundestrainer rin van Eik
sind halleneuropameister in Belgien
setzt sich das Team das wegen der
Olympischen Sommerspiele nicht in
Bestbesetzung angetreten ist im Endspiel
gegen Polen mit 5 Z2 durch auch ohne
einige für Olympia geschonte
Leistungsträger dominiert die deutsche
Mannschaft das Finale es dauert bis ins
zweite Viertel ehe eine Strafecke die
Führung bringt Kapitän döch mit einem
scharfen Ball in den Winkel kurz vor der
Pause bringt maskur das Team erneut in
Führung 2:1 nach 20 Minuten in der
zweiten Hälfte ist das deutsche Team
immer überlegener Pass in die Tiefe auf
maskur sein zweiter Treffer unter dem
polnischen Schlussmann hindurch zum 5 Z2
Endstand vollendet dann mertkens
Deutschland ist Europameister im
Hallenhockey zum 17 Mal bereits und zum
Wintersport Andreas Wellinger hat das
Weltcup skiespringen im heimischen
Willingen gewonnen bei schwierigen
Bedingungen mit Wind Regen und Pausen
verbesserte er sich als Sieb des ersten
Durchgangs mit 149 m im zweiten auf
Platz 1 vor dem Japaner i und dem
Schweizer
dejanten unbändiger Jubel bei Bob Pilot
Adam Amur und seinem anschieberbruder
isam sie sind die neuen Europameister
nach einem Fahrfehler des großen
Favoriten Johannes Lochner vor der
letzten Kurve im Eiskanal von
Sigulda Adam Amur der Lochner schon
gestern beim Weltcup in Lettland besiegt
hat fährt Bestzeit im letzten Durchgang
und sichert sich zugleiche mg Johannes
Lochner bleibt Bronze Francesco
Friedrich verpasst wie schon gestern als
Vierter das Podium
bei den Frauen kann bobpilotin Laura
Nolte mit Anschieberin Nele Schuten
ihren dritten Weltcupsieg der Saison
bejubeln im anspruchsvollen Eiskanal von
zulda fahren die beiden in ihrem
Schlitten in beiden Läufen Bestzeit auch
dieses Rennen wird zugleich als emtitel
gewertet für Laura Nolte bereits der
dritte nacheinander die wiesbadnerin Kim
kaliki sichert sich in Lettland
Silber und schon vorbei danke schön chr
wir haben noch die Wetteraussichten und
die gehen so im Nordosten Regen sonst
ist trocken und von Süden her immer
häufiger Sonne im Norden bei 6 bis 12°
stürmischer Wind im Süden ruhiger bei 12
bis
16° ja das war's von uns um 21:45 Uhr
gibt's das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka ab morgen hier Barbara hallweg
und jetzt geht's direkt weiter mit
Berlin direkt und shakunta la benergi